is this really what you want
and you are certain that what we are
doing is best for the people of the
kingdom
yes
i suppose it would in a sense
true
yes
it made me wonder
am i still that same person
[Music]
the era of myths gives way to an era of
great turmoil the continent was ravaged
by the devastating war between the
empire and the alliance
however
one nation remained unaffected by the
chaos
the kingdom of aletane
ward of the august
looked destined to have its soil stained
with the blood of battle
we've finally been called up we're up
against the empire's main army
we are to eradicate every last imperial
who comes ashore keep focused
come on everyone
[Music]
and now you will die
do you really have such a yearning for
war
i can't comprehend it
so then
what shall we do now
we're going to retake it
this is our chance while they're all
assembled
we should send our best and crush them
that's right
all the more reason to avoid bloodshed
it also likely means that we're in
danger
i suppose it is the only way for us to
survive
[Music]
playstation